I've been new people while need talk so
I can either swear at you or eat food
I've gotten so good at speaking with
confidence that I don't know if any of
this information is true the more upset
you get the funnier it is to me I love
it when you ask for a manager because
then I don't have to talk to you in your
car I can't find that information for
you because I'm too busy looking for
other jobs on my computer I take
bathroom breaks often so I can get a
moment of peace I love it when you
insult me over something that's your
fault because when you realize it's your
fault that moment of satisfaction is the
best thing ever
my college degree is gathering dust
because this is the only job I can get
right now sometimes calls come in so
quickly that I have to put you on hold
so I can finish telling my friend a
story I started ok so anyway Jessica ran
the ground and I know I know right
I wish quality assurance wasn't
listening so I could tell you how I
really feel there's a reason I work in a
call center it's cuz you don't want to
see the expression on my face when I'm
on the phone with you this isn't my real
voice I'm making myself sound much more
pleasant than I really am outbound calls
give me so much anxiety
I truly hope it goes to voicemail nice
for you are the more I'll try to help
you if you're a dick I'm gonna try and
get you off the phone as quickly as
possible so I can stalk you on Facebook
and make fun of you with my co-workers
if you're the worst person in the world
I will take your email address and sign
you up for weird email lists like brick
foot fetishes for furry or for erectile
dysfunction